so it's a great pleasure to be at this
nice place um
and i'm going to talk about some results
some
complexity of entangled covers maybe
thomas
would be a better fit for for this type
of talk
but at least we have him in in the room
and if i
say something stupid or you have some
questions that i cannot answer
um um you will help me out hopefully
uh so i'm also thanked to uh john
watchers who
who and and richard cliff who get me
interested in this
topic
so we're basically focusing on um
quantum share entanglement provers and
and
classical verifiers with exchanging
classical messages
so we won't be able to cover uh this uh
our related topics but
i guess for most of them um we will have
a good coverage
later on in this workshop um example the
session on prioritization theorems um
and and so we give a very quick uh uh
background of what we uh we'll talk
about so we have
um so two origins of our problem one one
is from the um
interactive uh pro systems and
multi-integral systems and and tcp
theorems that you have uh
heard uh about this uh in the first talk
and in the other region is from physics
side that we study entanglement and
non-locality and
and and and bare inequalities and and
these two two origins
are combined so nicely in its uh
uh model where where proverbs are
entanglement and we
verify the means classical and
motivation for for this
type of model is one from
the um interactive proof
system perspective view we in in that
systems we always allow our
provers to be all powerful and and it's
very natural in the quantum setting to
allow this prover to share entanglement
and and the other way to see it is it's
like a cs approach to study
braille inequalities and non-localities
so um i'll set up the
uh problems that we'll be discussing so
although we are we are also
discussing like uh interaction pro
multiple
attack proof systems with multiple
rounds but for most of time we will be
focusing on one run games
and and um therefore it's uh uh
necessary to
have some language to talk about it so
um in the setting for a dump you have
like two approvals and certain
entanglement
then the strategy of approvals that can
use this first a shared
state row and then measurement of
asa and btb we would have the convention
that questions were always in the
subsequent and answers were always in
the superscript
and and what we really need from quantum
mechanics is this
conditional probability when you have
question s and t and
and the probability that you get answer
a and b is this this form
the streets row of asa tensor btb
and and we will use this uh trace rule
uh
uh more in the talk
and it's actually defined as this uh
usual transform
and and we we're uh for simplicity we
sometimes
we only we always assume that this row
will have the same um system
and as the operators are acting on so
sometimes we would
uh omit the uh um taking the partial
trace of this of state they're using
and and first what is most important
parameter of these games is
they called the unlocal value of the
game and
it is simply the the maximum that you
can achieve with the
strategy um and this is just an
expression
of the winning probability where we're
always taking the expectations of the
questions and summation of the of the
answers and and
um since omega star is isn't is the
usual uh
quantity that we we uh talk about in
this setting
and and there's another related quantity
called uh fields value
where we simply replace uh drop this
this tensor here
and and we additionally we add a
commuting condition
so you can see that um any uh strategy
valid for this uh now local setting it
is automatically uh
strategy for for this field value of
definition because
this operators always commute um and and
so therefore
this omega f will be uh larger than or
equal to omega star
do we have any example where they're
different or we know that it's an
interesting question and and for
actually for any finite dimensions it
would
always stay the same are you allowing
infinite dimensional spaces yes
uh this introducing this uh uh omega f
is only only meaningful when you when
you're including
infinite dimensional systems otherwise
it will always be the same as the omega
star
and and and could it be that like with
uncountably infinite dimension you can
do more than with
because of the algebra that we're
considering is is like finally generated
would well be
sufficient to consider only
accountability infinite dimensional
systems
okay yes it's equivalent to an open
conjecture and operate outburst yeah so
we've mentioned that later on so so this
is like uh
the the most important quantity we will
be interested in is omega star but
we will also talk about uh briefly about
um
so this is the the the uh the uh
verifier that we decide whether to
accept
this uh question and answer pair so it's
just zero yes zero one and
one meaning we accept the the answers
um
so so um another like simplification of
technically uh assumption is
is when when these games are symmetric
you can always assume that strategies
are symmetric
it's kind of a nice uh a trick it
simplifies sort of things
and um
um so so for the game for the game
when when the provers when the game is
this metric means that um
we don't uh actually um distinguish
alice and bob
they would always be regarded as it's
the same
so there are two things for example
first uh
the game by definition itself is is
symmetric for example
the linearity test and then we we send
our uh query to to each proven and on
respect answers and and and there's
actually no no difference between them
so then under this assumption you can
you can assume that
the state grow is symmetric and and the
measurement they're doing
is the same
and and um so we will also be interested
in a particular
matrix norm called the arrow node this
row is a state
and it's defined in this form and it
turns out that this is
uh a very nice quantity to consider in
in another game setting
to argue about um
the distance of of management strategies
and and most importantly if two
measurements are closed in
in the distance induced by this norm you
can you can sort of replace
uh one by the other without disturbing
the system uh by much
um so this this will be the quantities
that it
will be interesting and i'll now let's
give you some examples of
of interesting non-local games that will
be uh
give us some intuition of this uh kind
of systems
so the first game that we will be
introducing is called the mermaid magic
square game
uh moment appears magic square game so
um you have this
magic square here where you have nine
variables and it's a
three by three and um we use this double
line to indicate that the parity of this
this column
is is odd and all other lines and
columns have even pairing
so classically it's it's a system that
has no solution because
the rows give you even paradigm columns
gives you odd parity
um and we we have such a consumer system
we consider again
build upon that and and and to do that
we sample
uh a constraint and one variable from it
and we send the the
constraint to the alice and variable to
bob
and then we check two things first
alice's answer is an assignment for for
the particular constraint
and bob is used as consistent check that
this for example this x5
is the same as the answer that is uh
given to us
so there are two checks and and
classically uh if
without the entanglement this kind of uh
to provoke game would
would would um correspond to the uh
certifiability of this uh constraint
system
if there is no uh certain diamond then
proverbs cannot always win
so we have some sort of soundness in the
classical case
and um so we call this a magical square
game because
um not only that this omega star the
quantum value is is larger than the
classical value
but also that the omega star is the
largest possible i and it as a property
it is one
so it means that the for this particular
uh game and symbol can always win
with actually two e power pairs
and and uh the generalization of this
model you can
you can consider any arbitrary
constraint systems with binary variables
and you can you can define a game upon
that and this is just the uh our binary
constraint system games that um
richard and mateo are discussing in the
paper
and um for example you can cons you can
rewrite any parity constraint as
s4 um as a formula of three sets with
four clauses right
each clause will rule out one
possibility and and then each each
constraint is
the uh for clause uh three set formula
and therefore the whole system
is a twenty clause reset formula and
what this example telling us is that um
this three-set formula is not set fiber
classically
but um actually there's a there's uh
accordance really to win the game
that that build upon this reset um our
formula
and and therefore it's meaningful to
define a problem called systar
and it's just a game that you consider
whether there's uh there's a
perfect strategy for approval to win
this game with shared entanglement
and and an example telling us that this
is actually a
new problem that other than
compared to this classical three-set
problem because sometimes you have
a classically no instance becoming yes
instance can you explain what is that
so this research star is a problem that
the importer is a suicide formula
and you have a bunch of three set uh
constraints and we ask whether
uh if you play the two-player game with
certain entanglement the provost can
always win
versus variables yes it's with uh it's
considered variable care
yes it's a game and it's now it's
defined on the game level but we will
later see on a more
constrained system level yes
but this game is not exactly a three
star uh star instance right because
if you select the line you select
several um
yeah you can you for for example you can
consider this instance and you select
only one
uh um three set constraint
so so each one will have four out of it
and and you you you
then reselect one of them sure what i
mean
doing this is even harder than what
would be required in the three-sided
start here
uh actually for this problem it's
because uh
like four clauses are selected and he
needs to
make four clauses true at the same time
yeah but
he needs to make one yeah but but um
what what this
uh magic square game shows you is that
um actually the proverbs can always
answer with
the right parity constraint so and this
means that every
four of the three set conditions are
automatically satisfied so exactly
yeah yeah he does but he achieves more
than he would yes
you can consider the game where you're
only at the cooper one class
and classically you can't win that game
because it's unsatisfiable by the yeah
i'm just saying it's a harder problem to
um to do merman
paris squares than to make a
corresponding cycle
and stuff yeah generally it will be a
it'd be a hard problem maybe but
for this particular instance here they
are equivalent um
sorry what are the 24 clauses here so we
have six
uh cl uh construct parity constraints
right row row row column column column
this
this you have six of them and each of
them can be represented as four
um three sets clause right
yes so so you have totally uh 24 of them
and the next example that we have
discussed is this so-called
quantum three current game it's another
um classically it's also where i'll
start the game and
and we also study this uh quantum
generalization using using a two-player
game
um so so the game we played is
we sample two vertices u and v of the
graph and and we we
challenge the uh provers to to give us
the colors
and we two checks first is a consistent
check
if they are given the same vertex they
should give give us the the
same color and in the second case if we
we give them two adjacent vertices and
and
we have to see uh two different colors
this is just very natural
um a game that you consider on top of
three curving game
problem and um so the claim here is that
there is such a graph g
which is it's finite and concrete uh uh
graph
and um you play that uh three current
game on the scan g
and the value column value will be one
but but it's actually not three
character graph
classically and and we will
of course such a problem uh so recurring
star
um asking whether the graph is is
coronally colorable
yes just like you translated
yeah sure you can you can think of it as
a three-set problem
yeah so there's because this recurrent
is this more special kind of
constraint um i don't know
yeah yeah sorry so so
you know this this difference has to do
with uh stp solution versus
integral solutions yeah you can you can
you can see that way
so then um can you also view is there
anything to be
to be obtained by looking at ways of
fixing stps you know
going to going to the next level of the
hierarchy or something is there is there
a natural interpretation there
of um versus the quantum games
we must see one implication in terms of
like um
actually we're considering operator
solutions of some equations
and and um and and it will correspond
into this uh
decision problem without
resulting into a game it's actually a
another mathematical problem
defined upon this consumer systems and
involving operators
so um and
and um so these two examples one's magic
square and then the current game
and they they're they're actually
what what they tell us is that
entanglement sometimes um um hurts um
sumness
for example the the the magic square
game that we can we come up with reset
uh uh
instances where it's actually not um
classically satisfiable but but
we have this um when you say
entanglement this this interactive
system
is never no longer sound because there's
no actually no
soundness at all for for for this um
shared entanglement uh system and and
well this you can think of this is there
a bug or a feature in our system
um and and we'll see
for some interactive systems it's
actually
a bug and a very big bug that we are not
able to fix
um so
um for for studying of uh multiple games
is
with intention and hangman the first
thing that we
understand very well is the two player
xor games
and it's based on this uh citizen
conversation of such games
and and um actually we can we can use
this result to show that um
um any the game value of this two-proof
one round with parity
um xor uh um
game will have a sdb uh characterization
and of expansion size
so therefore you can you can show that
actually this class
um is contained in expansion time and
and there are uh improvement on that
without
issuing uh by weakness that um um
discussed that
contained in qrp2 where krp2 is this
quantum
um two message integral system with
single uh prover
and and and this class is intension to
be uh
subclass of p space uh by by uh uh
uh alpaca and world chaos
so uh if you compare it to the classical
uh
complexity class um israel from uh uh
hassanas used that um
um this um um mfp
uh parity mip with with two players one
round
uh and at least for some uh constant uh
sumness and and
uh correctness uh parameters it's
the most general uh injectable system
you can have it's uh
in exp um so so um
unless we we have that uh next being
contained and p space
these two classes will be different and
and um
and what this means is that actually for
example you have like uh interactive
proof system in in
in in that sense and and when there's
entanglement
the sound is not um um we
we somehow heard sun is and making it
not about it in checkpoint system
and and therefore the the the capacitor
caused collapse
so yeah i'll get into that
yeah so um
and and the other result is a little bit
general than the sexual
uh uh game it's called unique game a
minigame um
in the classic setting is a very hard
problem and we don't don't know how hard
it is
and in the quantum case it's actually an
easy uh problem by by this um
uh rounding uh procedure um and
and you can also view it as as an
indication that encampment entanglement
can cause problems in our
systems
and and these problems are actually not
fixable if you
some assume some reasonable assumptions
on complexity causes
yeah yeah i would also like that point
of view but yeah we'll see you later
um
you have you have a previously sound
system but when you have entanglement
it causes a problem in your system so
yes in that sense it's a bug
so the next natural idea is this um if
you
consider more uh general
uh multi-programming type of systems is
it possible to to actually control the
behavior of the uh
verifiers
and and i found this picture very uh
described in our streaming here it's
actually a problem that you can buy
and and you can think of the dogs that
prove us and
and this product is called a tango free
dog leash
and this is actually actually what we we
want to do here we want to to somehow
uh design protocols for verify so so
that um he can control the behavior of
the provost and
and entanglement between them will not
matter
i don't know
so there are a bunch of techniques uh uh
in this uh
following this type of idea and and uh
for example we were discussing
consistent check and confusion check and
adding and
so the proveran and there are also a
private
information retrieval idea um that will
actually allow you to show a low bound
on on this class that you are asking
um so so we start with
private information trigger the idea is
that we we tricked the
the profile is trying to use the
entanglement but we somehow we we
actually hide our query to the provers
uh using this private information
retrieval scheme
so that they have no idea what we're
actually inquiry um
um and therefore you can you can argue
that entanglement won't help you much
and
and and therefore you have this lower
bound
and um so i'm fully we'll discuss uh
this uh
other uh three techniques are used in
restricting the drill of entanglement in
multiple integral
systems um so first uh the consistent
check is simply
that we send each prover the same
question and we expect the same answer
from them
and um so we already see this uh two
provokings in checking
in for example in this recurring game
and and
somebody tells you that it's not quite
strong enough to actually control the
behavior of the provers to show
entanglement
because in the current game we still
have this strange behavior that
causes a bug of our system um but but
it depends on i guess it's been on on
what's
the original uh particle is and and it
is an interplay between the original
particle and and
the the consent check that you are they
are adding
maybe there are some some other systems
where two-player
consent check would also allow you to um
limit the the entanglement um so there's
also
like a three player constraint checks
used in
for example the narrow test and
multi-linear test um
um actually issuing tune uh um
breakthrough route for for the lower
bound on
on memphis star and and um um
another use of this three period this
check is in in
in the paper by uh um ito
uh kobayashi predators they actually
used uh this
um add this check uh consent check to
the
so-called pcp simulation test where the
cquery
pcp
procedure are simulated in the system
so the consistency checks are are um but
only as a sub
test that we use and also
very important concept in defining and
improving
these uh theorems for as a
as a measure of of closeness and
and we were we are using this uh um so
what does it mean so we can we define
this concept
to measurement as as a property that
they will have the same answer
and and the income consistency as uh the
gives the different counters and um the
importance of of this
thing is first is very easy to analyze
you get this kind of quantities right uh
on the structure of the game
and the other thing is that um you can
prove uh a system like this
where uh this is this distance between
two
measurements is some uh somehow bounded
by the inconsistency of a and b
and if you you can argue the distance
you can argue this inconsistency between
a and b
you have a boundary on that and you can
use the place of
of proverb argument
um so the other check is called
computing check it's
quite similar to the uh consistent check
but um
um this time we would uh uh trick uh uh
alice
we we we don't tell alice what what is
the actual question where we are doing
consistent check
and so we sample a pair of questions and
send this pair to alice and and
and one of the questions to bob and and
we we we checked that uh whether
they give the same answer on on this
particular question queue
and um you can use that um
actually this kind of technique is used
uh to show that it's
hard to compute this uh integral value
um up to an inverse polynomial precision
and this is a lemma uh showing here why
this kind of test would be helpful
essentially where uh if you have a
high successful ability bringing this uh
confusion game
then um you have structures on bob's
measurement it's kind of
a commuting constraint with um
yes and and in the original magic square
game we actually don't have this
uh confusion check we if you add this
confusion check you will you will we
will fix the problem
yes yes yes
and we will see uh so why this check is
useful and and we have a
more clear picture in later discussions
so i didn't understand what what should
the so
suppose you give alice q and q prime
what should her answer be and let's pick
an example
as the magic square game what's q and q
prime and what's her answer should be
well the answer would be uh um
to to think of it as what's the
assignment of the variable of
x i of that next j and you should answer
zero one for each of the variables right
and and
uh and yeah that's that's the question
so you're asking
here yeah a pair of variables and and uh
for the other player we only ask one of
them two rows or two
so it's two rows in the case of the
magic square game no two variables
it's it's kind of strange because you're
asking pairs of variables where on
originally you ask for three variables
yes yes
so sometimes sometimes you ask alice for
two variables
that might be different rows yes yes
yeah that's the idea right
right so and bob's always gets a
variable right so bob
doesn't know yes that's crazy picture
the confusion test does sometimes
ask the lower question and sometimes ask
at least two bob questions
yes yes okay um so another technique is
simply added at an asset player and it's
um well known
um property of monogamy uh of
entanglement
where where it basically says that if
alice is highly entangled with bob
then the nuclear system cannot be
entangled
highly with bob prime and
so you can you can use this type of
argument by adding above prime
and doing exactly what bob supposed to
do and
um you can you can use this type of
argument to
choose the hardness of three player
games and actually you can you can shoot
you can see easily why this works for
like magic square game because like a
square game you have two ep up
uh shared between a and b and if you
also allow bob to to
uh a and b prime to have the same uh
property then then alice will have
trouble because
she won't know how to share the epr pair
between b and v prime and you can also
use this kind of
argument um and this time with like we
randomly choose
uh two players out of three players
costco is kind of nonsense
but but quantumly works sometimes and
and actually this is what uh
vidiq did in the uh low degree test but
i guess we don't know whether it's
actually needed but currently
um it's how it is proved
this and also the confusion when you
take the magic square game
you have this perfect strategy that wins
the quality one yes
this is questionable so if you change
the game a little bit yes yes yes
yes either you do this for the free
version of the magic square game
or you keep two players but you ask this
yes yes
yes
yeah so this this all these techniques
can be viewed as how you can fix the
problem
that that new camera has caused in our
system
um so um maybe i don't have enough time
i'll skip this slide so basically you
can use this uh uh type of uh
uh techniques to to prove that there's
mp hard to distinguish
uh the the um these two cases either the
omega
equals one or except most one minus some
one over
uh polynomial um
and then the argument that we use is is
simply um the
so-called state emery slammer um with
bob prime technique
because um
this state here is simply the post
measurement state when you do
bq measurement and and the distance
is somehow bounded by the self
consistency of the
bob's measurement
and and we have this type of uh
serum one one idea to to round it to the
classical
um strategy is you repeatedly measure
the state
with different measurements and you
would somehow get answers
but of course the problem is we have
like bad soundness in
this this type of one over um
some polynomial and then if you screw it
up in in
um mip style it will will show you
some um um containment of next with but
with
especially small sun is scraggly scab
so the the um next uh
result that we'll be spending more time
discussing is this a nice
low bound on maybe star actually um it
proves that mf star because uh
an expert and an airspace is is
are contained in mp star
um and you can you can think of it as
above being fixed for all particles any
any classical injection proof system
multiple
intensive proof systems you can you can
um modify it and so that
it becomes some entanglement resistance
and
um and actually this is best we can hope
for using this type of entanglement
recent techniques
because we um that is is to restrict
the use of entanglement and and the best
you can hope is
um um prove that um the classical
interactive systems is contained in star
does that cost you uh extra approvals to
do this procedure
but yeah this class is fun is polynomial
when in progress so we don't care
actually it's oh that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah sure we don't care how many
progress but but actually there's a
question we now
probably only only be able to show that
three three players
can contain an but we don't know whether
players can also
um improve i guess so but can you
explain your
second point
you can modify it yeah yeah so so this
is
so obviously there are some uh multiple
child proofs that that are
not not so good when there is
entanglement
right so but but what this style shows
that
if you do this machinery of using
polynomials and then doing doing
multi-linearity tests then actually this
is a different proof system
of the same problem but now you can
prove that it's entanglement resistance
okay
those modified uh provers are there
still in the honest case classical
or do you need quantum uh the proverbs
are a quantum
you can share entanglement and you can
show that i mean they almost prove us i
mean if you want to
uh well for honest proofers yeah you can
win the
class clean so you you achieve this
so the the protocol the secure protocol
is a classical protocol but that is
secure against quantum proof
yeah you can see that yes
um so um the proof of this
result is followed
quite closely to the classical proof of
containment of the next pin
in mip and um basically what needs to be
done is
is that the multi-unit test is sound
against uh
intact improvers and and i would uh now
by the
multi-unit test you consist uh two tests
one is consistent test and the other is
ordinary uh multi-unit test
which is essentially the um um
access align the linearity has to choose
an access and and
and send for three points and uh cut see
whether the answers are are linear in
this uh
on these three points and and
classically
the the proof uh is basically you can
ensure that um the provers will be first
to use uh common multilingual function
to answer your questions
and and and quantity it's even not clear
how um
such a statement would be formalized uh
because you have like um
measurement operators given this x and
and you measure and you get some answers
and and what does it mean to be close to
to some
multi-linear function and and this is
how
they they find the solution and it says
that um actually you
use there exists a measurement vg
where it doesn't look at the input of of
the x
and any queries you just measure measure
and get a multi-linear function and end
the answer with this this multi-linear
function
so this is basically the claim and if
you if you if the strategy of
ax were using this symmetrical
assumption
so um ax would be abc's strategy
and they win this game with
in both uh consistent sets and
homogeneous with this high probability
then
then um you can prove that um you can
replace this uh
v measurement the the original ax
measurement with some
something vg where it doesn't really
depend on
x at first first measure a g and then
use this input x and a brain answer and
once this is uh obtained then you can
replace
the e x with these and and and um
and essentially we will have uh a
situation where where
players actually uh um sample this
same multilinear function to to um
to play and so this is uh what um
um tuition and thomas showed in in the
paper
and and and the way that um
the assuming is this kind of induction
on on
number of variables we we can depend
we remove the dependency on our
measurements of variables one by one
and and in the proof the what technical
difficulties is that when you do that um
the error in terms of inconsistency
growth especially
and you sort of need a uh
consolidation step and which uses sdp
and
and the structure of the proof is quite
similar to the classical one but
the consolidation step is rather
complicated
and technically and and actually we
you have to do to do something active uh
change to to a measurement
to to to achieve uh such uh statements
so
um i will not be able to uh
uh tell you more details about this uh
main step but to give you some flavor of
how techniques are used in the proof by
introducing
the induction step where we simply
remove dependency of one variable
so what is a statement we will find a
measurement
that that only depends on uh n minus
so the x is a triple of elements from f
where um this uh uh
x uh negation i is this the string where
we just remove the ice element
and therefore its melamine doesn't look
ice coordinate and
and it gives a linear function as a
result and
and the way that uh this is playing the
game is
first you do this measurement and then
um you just use this linear function
applied on x i and get result so this is
basically
um um what the the induction initial
step that we
are uh doing and then first uh uh how do
you how do you come up with such a
measurement
you only have like a measurement give
you x and and give it a result
and now you you cannot depend on this um
ice coordinates for some random i and
the way that um uh
um they come up with the solution is you
just choose two random
points on the ice position and and then
do the measurement
and you give give you some result and
then you just
define the line to be the line that
going through these two points
so this is how how this measurement come
up and
and uh so we only need to show that for
this particular measurement
you have this kind of statement
and and the proof is is really about
controlling the errors
so the first step is is simple you just
expand the the expression
bx here and you get a huge expression
here it's like a
tracer of three tensors and um
on this this one is simple because the
summation of i is gives you identity
um so the first uh approximation that we
will use we
we restrict the e prime to be one
particular value of
uh that the can have and the intuition
is is for from the
consistency check because um in that
part
we already measure ax prime and get
results l
um x i prime so um by the consistency
check uh uh
assumption um the only main contribution
that um
when the third player is measuring is
this give get getting listed
out so up to some error epsilon um you
can you can drop or
other a primes this is the first step
the second step is is
a little more complicated and but the
idea is is very simple we just simply
want to remove these two two terms here
and why you can do that it's actually an
argument of
we have already seen is called the state
in variance because
um measuring this or not doesn't doesn't
really disturb the system
um very much so you can you can remove
it and up to some error
square of the s plumb you have this kind
of
result and then you just remove this uh
in inequality here
this happens with the the equality only
happens with one over
um the the size of the the the field so
it's also uh small when the field is
large
and therefore you have i have this here
and
and finally this is simply the
assumption on the
multi-linearity test that you have so
finally you get this assumption that
consistency of a and b
are high and therefore they are they are
closed and you can replace it
so this is basically um
the proof of the the first step and then
it actually um give us a nice lower
bound of
magic star
so what about our phones um
unfortunately
nothing concrete is known and for
example you can use
a random projection approaches to
somehow reduce
measurement dimension because we don't
have a bond on on the
shared measurement there is bob can use
and if you can bounce dimension you can
you can
have at least some up bomb but uh it
doesn't seem to work
and there's nice results um um using a
non-community of positive sensors
which essentially give you an sdb
hierarchy that you can approximate this
omega f
from above and and it's also trivial to
see that
by increasing dimension larger and
larger you can have an algorithm to
approximate or make a star
but the question is with whether these
two are the same if it's not something
these two algorithms cannot combine to
to an algorithm to decide
to approximately either list one of
they're the them they don't understand
what does that mean if it's the same
then you can combine this two algorithm
to at least through that
these quantities are excitable yes
but that's yeah there's nothing more
than decidable
yes i guess nothing more because we
don't know how far this will converge
is that uh correct
settled the whole i mean he really
proved that the problems are completely
equivalent
okay oh i don't know that they are
completely equivalent i mean we would be
happy to know whether the common vetting
problem is decidable i mean at the
moment we just don't know anything it's
okay it's we don't know anything whether
con embedding problem is true
that's a big problem on operate i mean
one of the three
large biggest open problems on a very
diligent one where just nobody has a
clue
period every
hyper finite factor is compatible in the
ultra product
you know no every one factor isn't
better with the hyperfinite vector but
it's it's a it's uh equivalent to having
matrix models
if you ever heard something about free
probability in matrix models
that's where it belongs to and what
would it imply even
so if the constant embedding conjecture
is true then these two are the same then
then we have at least some decidability
it's it's if and only i mean if these
are the same and condom batting is true
and vice versa
okay
is the statement that these two are the
same yeah
can you say again so how do you define
these two in terms of you know is it a
supreme
dimension or is it defined directly
you said if the two quantities are the
same then
yes can we say again what the quantities
are
precisely i mean i know
um okay so so the difference is that
omega star is calculated by looking
at povms which are in finite dimensional
and tensor product position
whereas omega star pretends the prior
position whereas omega f just
allows arbitrary infinite dimensional
operators which commute
so whether you know whether every
commuting family can be approximated by
a matrix
i mean approximated in some sense by by
commuting matrices
which then necessarily have to be
intense or for our position because in
finite dimension
commuting means sensor product position
right
yeah so the difference omega star is
defined as a supremum over increasing
dimensions
don't think about the sdp hierarchy but
okay that's okay
um so now we we somehow uh get back to
the question of whether
this kind of magic square games are
indeed a bug of our system
um one reason is is
with this integral relation technique we
can only show like lower bounds and
there's no hope that we can show
um something outside of mip um
to be inside this mp star and and um
um one interesting um direction to look
at is this
um we don't we don't add this
additional tracks to enforce the
behaviors and we just let dogs
um do what they would want to do and and
see
what actually this class would give us
um
and and to stop the investigation it's
quite natural to to to at least
ask um what's what's the guess in that
case uh complexity of this kind of
problems
so for example we we consider um a
binary constraint system game
and and and we simply ask what's the
when would the provers will have the
winning strategy in the quantum sense
and this is a nice paper by uh uh
richard and
urjet um i'm saying that um if this is
if and only if when when the
corresponding uh confused system has
so-called
quantum satisfying assignment so what is
a coordinate set of assignment
um it should be some sort of assignments
and but this quantum
and and the way we define it first we
transform uh
a constrained system to to uh
uh constraints of polynomials and we
only require that um
um so the polynomials the roots of
polynomials
on the boolean cube were coincide with
with this uh
original constraint and you can always
do that and then
uh this uh quantum set for an assignment
is simply assignment
of of operators matrices finite
dimensional matrices to
to the uh our variables and they are
they are self-adherent information
matrices
and uh what makes them assignment first
you you when you replace these variables
with matrices you get an identity of a
matrices this is quite natural to
to assume and this the second condition
is simply the binary condition that we
have for the variables is x squared x x
now this the third condition is kind of
interesting so it says that um
uh in order to to be asset fine
assignment each variable
um xg and sk occurring in the same
constraint must be commuting
and this is technically a necessary
condition because you want to
replace variables with matrices and and
polynomials are committing
it doesn't make sense if you replace a
non-community matrix in this polynomial
and i guess this more deeper reason is
analysis are given constraints and and
are allowed to ask to to do measurements
be using these operators
essentially and and um the cumulativity
of those matrices
allow her to actually observe all the
quantities simultaneously and
otherwise for non-computing matrices you
know so-called um
certain principle and then you won't be
able to observe all the variables you
want
so um this condition is kind of uh
interesting and we give it a name called
locally commutative condition and and
simply says that every variable on on
the constraint should should be
commuting
so once we have a quantum definition of
consists of an assignment we can ask
whether a constitution is quantumly
satisfied with a new definition of
certain stability
right
so let's um review this concept using
the magic square game
the magic square game has indeed a
quantum set of enzymes in this form
where these matrices are two by two poly
matrices
and um we were cheating a little bit
because these are square to identity
images but
we're working on plus minus domain and
previously we're talking about 01 domain
but it doesn't really matter and and you
can check that
every row will have matrix product 1 and
and this column will have matrix product
minus one identity
um and one one observation is actually
uh found by the local uh commodity
condition every
uh operator on same row or column will
be commuting
and another observation is that um i
need to meet you system
not on the same rule align column
develop the anti-community
and and um and this is uh for this
particular solution and you can actually
prove that for any solution
uh of course sets an assignment of the
magic square game
it will always be the case any two um
variables not coming from the same row
or column
they must end commute and you can use
this as a gadget to
to actually grow this magic square
together and and prove some
entanglement dual bounds using our
plantation series of
of clifford algebra so
is there any relation on the dimension
where this operator live and the
dimension of the entanglement you need
to yeah yeah yeah so the sizes of the
matrices
is just the dimension that you want okay
yeah
um so um let's test your intuition of
what we are defining as a coordinate set
for diamonds we
we add a trivial constraint which is uh
f
depending on x2 and x4 but it's actually
always accepting it's always true um um
trivial constraint
so what what then what does this system
mean we have like uh this
six constraint and then this one
additional
triple constraints actually f is always
one
always always satisfied but artificially
it depends on the two variables
and it doesn't make sense for for
classical problems but we'll see if we
translate this
um to a to opponent game then actually
what you would be doing is analysis and
two variables
and bob isn't one of them this is what
we have already seen is the
confusibility check right
and and by definition of quantum center
assignment
what you will um see that now this new
uh system doesn't have a certified
assignment because
we say that 22 f2 and x4 must be
assigned anticommuting variables
but now this trivial constraint will
actually um inverse x2 and x4 to be
commuting
and therefore there's no no no operator
solutions to to this
new system by adding this new constraint
although it's trivial
right um so this this kind of
other one can show that um original
switch has started with some sort of uh
um trivial function constraints we will
will give you uh sort of this this kind
of problems are
hard using using your vedic
atomizer to give
adding this confusion check and and
consider check out two to this but we'll
give you
some harnessing but yeah this would be
another view we just add this kind of uh
trivial constraint
it's not quite like a preset constraint
because we
you cannot actually represent it in this
reset but but this is how
um these are connected
you should help too
well i mean i mean the results are you
have a gap
that yeah yeah
um so another thing that is natural to
consider is we now have the new
definition of receptivity problems
called star problems and and it's it's
whether the problem is whether you can
reduce
one to each other and and it's nice to
have and and
and the idea is that it's actually
possible we we actually
can do that uh from from taking any
upgrade classical reduction
and and some gadget on that so
um and
and the problem that we will have is in
in if you have a
this research system will have a quantum
set of assignments where
you can easily come up with this
coloring measurement for
uh um quantity occurring gain
um because of the local uh connectivity
uh condition of the operators
and and um but on the other direction
it's kind of uh
harder to to
all right so in other direction
we have problems because for example we
want to read off
the operator x1 from from this node and
and x2 from that node
then we don't know even whether they are
commuting or not so
um we designed some sort of gadgets um
using graph constraints and
ensure that um the for this particular
graph
which is a triangular prism and and um
the claim is that uh any current
measurement for for a and e will be
commuting
and and this is only constrained on this
to node
so and and the proof of this uh only
condition called extendability is this
kind of classical uh
thing it's easy to check and to to
establish cumulativity
essentially you are trying to to say
that the commutator of of these
variables are
in ideal generated by the coloring
constraints and
and and these ideas are and the readings
are
non-communicative so um
generally this uh ideal membership
problem is understandable and
and and for this particular case and you
can use
some um techniques from
non-communicative global based computing
to to assist the
the proof and and once you have uh
the schedule you can you can recover the
the reduction
by by assigning uh by by connecting uh
identify this a and e
with two antivirus that you want to the
cumulativity between them
so the the
the commotivity gadgets for some
problems are actually very very easy to
to construct for example
by using local cumulativity condition um
this would be a
preset uh connectivity gadget for two
variable x1 and x2
and and um um so
this is how i previously issued that
suicide story isn't hard
and and actually what this
um is doing is it's actually another
confusion check in disguise
because this y variable isn't is a new
variable and and as
bob will always know that you can assign
it to one and without loss anything
and and
and when you when you sample this kind
of uh constraints is essentially given
two variables and and then
and bob is one of them and this is
another um
confusion check to do what we do um
and and therefore you can you can
actually embed all this confusion check
and consistent check
inside of of the constraints so you you
actually do not need this kind of
additional constraint then
and say that this this this swiss star
is isn't
hard even with um some some gap
and of course the the the uh
the problem is that we don't know is how
hard exactly this resets done
and the difficulty comes in because we
don't have a bound on dimension of the
operators that we are seeking for
and and um um because if it's
interesting to
to have um what we are discussing now is
exactly this
harness if you can you can some come up
some ideas to the prop
to to relate this to to approximate case
then then
something interesting would happen
um so to summarize we can we can have
sort of non-local np theory
consider a lot of star problems um some
from uh satisfiability and some from
graph problems
and we also can see that these two
problems
two sister and once a star are easy
and we are sort of the situation where
we can establish uh
a local chiefess dichotomy serum but um
um there's a little problem uh of the
front set star
where you have constraints of the
parities like the magic square
and and we don't know how hard this kind
of problem is it's not shown to be
hard as as hot as recessed and it's not
known in p
and uh only for some uh subclass of this
game we know that it's easy to handle
uh by uh alex on archibald
and it's an interesting uh connection to
uh graph
primarily um
so so i guess the the question that um
also a problem that we have for for this
bcs problem star problems is they always
use
epr pairs in the perfect strategy and um
it's kind of a good thing for having a
simple structure but
also a question whether this this is a
special chrono orbit that we are looking
at is it as general as as
exactly as harness because we always
involve that epr pairs
um so i would quickly go through the uh
uh sort of uh
ideas on how you can actually define
well with another quantum pcp thermal
conjecture we have uh
a famous one in canada in hamptonia
complexity um
definition and and i guess on on the
game level you can also
uh consider like uh the hardness of
approximation of number of games as a
definition of
of a quantum pcp and and um you can you
can see
whether a constant approximation of
mixture isn't called as a version of
uh um pcp serum and this is actually
achieved with three provers
and and and um but but maybe this
because um this kind of uh
omega star the hardness of approximately
that and and
and the class of ambi star we actually
don't know what's
actually hardness is so maybe it's more
more safe to
to claim a pcp serum as a
self-contained statement whether the the
approximation of omega star is as hard
as
exactly determine the value is this one
um it depends on how you how you um see
the problem
and and you can also sort of define
pcp's um
based on more proof verification style
and and
have some restrictions on on the on the
uh proof that
that there are no local uh conditions on
proof stream and and um
um and from from this uh magic square
game and and
it seems like also a possibility to to
use only sim one prover but restricting
um the case where where the when they
ask the queries the queries must be
commuting uh
observables so you kind of might lead
you to a different
definition of this nice
conjectures and this is
what i will say and thank you for
attention
are there any questions
do you have an afterthought in the
dimension you need
depending on the number of questions
no i don't so it could be that that with
this type of games
uh you get you get yeah it would be nice
to have kind of a game with a constant
number of inputs and outputs for which
you need
unbounded templates for infinite
dimension to
oh we don't have such examples but but
they could exist
yeah you're according to the facebook
yes yes okay
can you explain why we feature i
understood
feature well the feature is um well this
kind of uh
games are you do why does it bark
because we are thinking of it
against the costco satisfying problem
right and
and what we are underneath is actually
this is discussing
of a new kind of satisfactory problem
it's called quantum central problem
and for that problem it's not a bug it's
a kind of new new kind of uh problem
that we are starting it's
it's kind of a feature of the system
and that argument is satisfying
because um if you consider that you
you stick with classical satisfying
problems then
obviously the entanglement comes in and
causes problems and but
um actually what this kind of to player
games are our studying is is a new kind
of uh
set viability question and and um you
cannot say that it's sparkful for that
kind of
it's investigation feature because it
keeps us off the streets
okay so maybe we should uh wrap it up uh
and um
it'll just be a short break uh we'll
reconvene in
eight minutes i guess um stretch your
legs and
it'll be not a talk but uh kind of a
discussion
uh session and it'll actually continue
on some of the same
topics so let's just have a short break
and let's thank something again